الآن بعد أن علمنا أن حوالي 25 إلى 50 في المائة
من الأشخاص ينشرون
أعراضًا ، فإننا نقترح أن الناس
كانوا أغطية وجه من القماش بينما
يوصي البيت الأبيض بأن نرتدي
أقنعة الوجه في الأماكن العامة ، وقد بدأت بعض الولايات في جميع أنحاء
البلاد في جعل هذا
إلزاميًا وقعت على أمر تنفيذي
والذي  سيتطلب ارتداء أقنعة
أو أغطية للوجه عند التواجد داخل أي من متاجر البيع
بالتجزئة ، ويتساءل الكثيرون عن
القناع الذي يوفر أفضل حماية
الآن عندما نتحدث عن أغطية الوجه ،
فهناك الأقنعة الجراحية التي أرتديها
في المستشفى لحماية المرضى من
الجراثيم الخاصة بي وتجنبها  أي بقع
ثم هناك أقنعة التنفس n95
التي يجب أن تكون مناسبة تم اختبارها من أجل
حماية العاملين في مجال الرعاية الصحية أثناء
إجراءات معينة ، إنها الأقنعة الوحيدة من
هذه الأقنعة التي تمنع دخول معظم
الجزيئات الصغيرة جدًا عند
استخدامها بشكل صحيح ، نحتاج إلى الاحتفاظ بهذه
الأقنعة في  أيديهم ثم هناك
أقنعة القماش التي يمكن التخلص منها والتي يمكنك شراؤها
من متجر وعلى الإنترنت هم ليسوا كذلك  صُنعت
للجراحة أو للمستشفيات ولكنها تستخدم
أيضًا على نطاق واسع أوصى مركز السيطرة على الأمراض (CDC)
بأن نرتدي جميعًا أقنعة وجه من القماش مثل
هذه التي صنعتها ابنتي عندما
نخرج في الأماكن العامة ولا يمكننا أن
نبتعد جسديًا عن بعضنا البعض
ونضع في اعتبارنا  السبب ليس
حماية أنفسنا كثيرًا ولكن لحماية
الآخرين منا ، لا ينبغي أن يكون
مفاجئًا أن تكون أقنعة الدرجة الطبية
هذه أكثر فعالية ولكن هذا لا يعني
أننا يجب أن نتجاهل الاستفادة من أقنعة القماش ،
دعني أريكم إلقاء نظرة  في
هذه التجربة التي أجراها باحثون في
المعاهد الوطنية للصحة ،
استخدموا الليزر للمساعدة في إظهار المدى الذي
تنتقل إليه قطرات البصاق في الهواء عندما
نتحدث ، شاهد إلى أي مدى تذهب تلك النقاط الخضراء
عندما يتحدث بدون أشعة الليزر ،
فقد تكون هذه القطرات غير مرئية للعراة.
لكن الآن بقطعة قماش ، بالكاد نرى
أي تسارع يخرج على
شكل سحابة غاز ، وبالتالي فإن ارتداء
الأقنعة يمكن أن يكون حتى لو
لم تكن درجة عالية وسيلة لاحتواء
مجموعة من تلك السحابة ليديا بيريبا هي
أستاذة في معهد ماساتشوستس للتكنولوجيا تدرس الفيزياء
الكامنة وراء كيفية انتشار الأمراض من
خلال السعال والعطس والتنفس ،
والتي لها أعلى قوة دفع ،
يمكن أن تساعد بعد ذلك هذه القطرات في الوصول إلى
مسافات تصل إلى ثمانية أمتار إلى 26
قدمًا.
من حيث زخمهم ويمكنهم
بشكل أساسي إحضار قطرات تصل إلى 16 إلى 19
قدمًا ثم الزفير هو الثالث في
الخط وإحضار القطرات إلى
المصدر حوالي ستة أو سبعة أقدام ، يمكنك
الآن معرفة سبب ارتداء قناع بالإضافة
إلى التباعد الجسدي  من المهم جدًا
أن تسافر جراثيمك بعيدًا ، ونريد
أيضًا التأكد من أن هذا القناع نظيف أيضًا بشكل
صحيح بحيث لا
يصبح أيضًا مصدرًا للتلوث الثانوي
ولا يتعين عليك أن تكون
أزيزًا مع ماكينة الخياطة مثل بلدي
ابنة ، التي شيرت قديم أو باندانا
ستفعل في النهاية يتعلق الأمر بوجود
شكل من أشكال الحاجز مع طبقات متعددة